[Musica]
portava dove avvicinarsi allo specchio
non successo e un ascensore super tico
perché ci porta in un posto superfigo
pensi di procedere allora
c'è la cassaforte oggi scassinato una
cassaforte e vedremo che cosa c'è di un
prezioso all'interno ce la faremo
ragazzi
ma no ma perché ci sei tu come premio
dove sono i miei lingotti d'oro
e allora adesso vi faccio vedere due
siamo allora vi spiego perché è una roba
un po complicata pro famiglia era la
foto fammi vedere il mazzo
mamma mia come sono venuto bene sono
proprio bello ma comunque tavolara ci
tengono tutti grazie anche la mia mamma
me lo dice siamo sul set del videoclip
di della ragazza melanzana ciao ragazze
e no nel senso del colore vorrei
comunque sia ci sta a casa qualche
stranissima adesso la faccio vedere
a parte che ci sono gli aquiloni
attaccati dove poi nella casa di un
artista che ha un gusto sinistro nel
mettere delle cose attaccate al muro
tipo questa maghetti e su gusti ragazzi
su cui si io metto le cose strumento da
lui mette questo sul soffitto poi c'è la
doccia e la ragazza della doccia ciao
raga tracciate su sta roba insomma se il
bastone della pioggia tipo avevo in
questa casa è tutta così stranissima io
mi sto mettendo a montare questo video
che state vedendo è stata lei l'avete
vista tutti tutti l'avete vista è colpa
sua
sempre casino fai sempre casino ma ce la
fai
noi non ce la fa ragazzi non ce la fa
sono i problemi
voi non potete capire ma questo blog mi
piace un sacco di gol più bello che
abbia mai registrato
[Musica]
adesso la giulia ci spiega una cosa di
questa casa vieni giù italiani sta
adesso tu guarda questi libri livelli di
vedi che sono legati ad esso tu ci
spieghi perché il proprietario di questa
casa lega i libri ha paura che scappino
no allora
li tiene legati perché perché perché se
fai invisibili diceva i bicipiti ma
potrei sapere che dai vicini
complimenti va bene ragazzi vi lascio la
prima clip di questo blog che diciamo
che la settimana scorsa ho registrato un
video con stefano e le cose sono andate
diciamo così quando tu organizzi un
video con uno youtuber praticamente che
cosa succede
vi mettete d'accordo e ha un orario vi
vedete su skype su twitpic e poi
registrato un video insieme ecco quando
io mi sono messo d'accordo con stefano
avevo detto ci vediamo alle 5 facciamo
il video sono 25 20 e stefano mi ha
mandato questi due vocali su whatsapp e
gli faccio ascoltare
sto ancora caldo bru questo era il primo
dopo ben quindici minuti da quel vocale
lì mi arriva questo finito scusa forse
mi sono fatto prendere la mano e ho
fatto un paio di festa grazie stefano
volta facciamo il bidet sotto la sedia
davanti al computer è ancora anche un
altro vocale ma mandato ancora a basta
muoviti come adesso mi spieghi quali che
pro che problemi spiegano cosa ti a
intestino poi hai appena cagato vai a
mangiare tanto io sono sono svuotate
riempirmi di mondo
bene adesso faccio ascoltare anche il
tuo ultimo vocale capisco grazie prego
sembra stefano nei micro lo metto sempre
dentro perché qualcosa succede sempre a
caso proprio la seconda clip di oggi è
anche il perché sono qua praticamente io
e giulia abbiamo partecipato a un
videoclip di gabry ponte e io ho fatto
la reaction al video finito perché
ovviamente è sempre bello prevedere un
lavoro finito quando passi una giornata
sul set fare le riprese
buona visione
[Musica]
[Applauso]
seconda
dami rivederlo vi sono eccitato
secondo sarà un casino rimorchiare
adesso quotidiane possiamo anche dire
che io una ragazza vive nella mia vita
[ __ ] [ __ ] l'ho baciata quindi ragazzi
non ho potuto farvi vedere il video
integrale perché perché sono celiaco e
quindi però che il video poi quando
completo vi piaccia che uscirà appunto 3
aprile durante la settimana sono
successe un altro paio di cagate ad
esempio con jack nobile che ha provato a
farmi dei del i trucchi di magia
il risultato è stato questo ciao sono
giocabili all anno si rifà ai farisei e
vi faremo vedere un gioco di immagine
incredibile di aver segnato io però
insediate nelle mani di metil ematico si
è così pochi giorni e stringe patti
prima è una ics fino a prova continua a
proporre come in dieci rate e questa
deve scomparire dalla mia monaco marina
ma l'altra vicenda
oggi la magia scarseggia o forse no
già che scompare così e straniere nei
ghetti no per mostrare non è possibile
sta roba di aspettare possibile amarezza
dice inchiostro no va bene
per impedire di tutte e tutti tutto bene
ma che mai mai mai
infine ragazzi vi volevo dire che tra me
e intesa c'è intesa è abbattuto
incredibile no vabbè in poche parole mi
hanno invitato al festival di giovani di
gaeta che si terrà il 6 aprile e quindi
mi troverete ii presso lo stand di
intesa sanpaolo 15 vediamo la ragazza io
concludo questo episodio incredibile
sono dovuto uscire perché stavano
registrando ancora videoclip non mi
andava di tartassare le scatole a girare
ogni volta che devo volgare ma se non è
niente spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto sta passando gente e io quando
passa agenti non riesco a bloccare
perché mi sento tutto vergognoso niente
cazzi propri questo video sia piaciuto
come un momento è un bel live anche vari
social come di trascrizione questi
scheletri ci vediamo il prossimo video
bella ragazza
[Musica]